in grandeur pet laura and riga treaty
that left ukrainian partner totally
without any assistance the discussion
that is going on in polish
historiography concerning this subject
is dominated by this particular problem
whether Pilsudski could be could be
condemned as a man who didn't stand to
his agreement with his partner or he was
just forced due to two historical
circumstances to the fact that national
Democrats his opposition forces in
parliament dominated political scene in
poland and they were very strongly
opposed to any agreement with ukraine
and so on and so on actually i want to
mention two interesting positions in
this latest historiographical discussion
general position is that pusat ski was
forced and that actually the decisions
taken in a trigger conference with the
soviet russia delegation were
manipulated on the Polish side by the
national Democrats leader Stanislavski
who forced the rest of Polish delegation
to comply with his National Democratic
that is nationalist entire Ukrainian
stand however
both myself in several articles and
young historian from from Joseph young p
Solinsky with the help of substantial
new sources we tried to undermine this
position by showing that Pilsudski left
Ukrainian in Riga on purpose according
to peace Olinsky who studied very
interesting new materials from Roman all
our chi può suits key thought about
Soviet Ukraine at that time as future
possible maybe in some future possible
partner so in Riga he wanted to make
Soviet Ukraine stronger seeing in pet
Laura just the lost cart that was with
no actual use and this Soviet Ukraine
when it was a part in in Riga treaty
could be strengthened according to Roman
all that is very important political 82
Pilsudski at Riga and so episode ski
decided to actually get rid of of pet
Laura as his real partner however he
helped but Laura afterwards on personal
grounds rather from my point of view
suit he just decided not to intervene at
Riga at all because he was interested at
that time only in finding a new
strategic
grounds for defending Poland and he
already was persuaded that he's fight
for independent you creative sorry set
the semi-independent Ukrainian bath
estate was lost in 1920 so this is just
one of the examples of historiography
history or graphical debates that take
place over the subject of 1920 the
problem of the subsequent Ukrainian
immigration living in Poland I mean pet
Laura and Ukrainian State Ukrainian
State connected to that Laura are also
very much analyzed in interesting new
monographie in Polish historiography I
can mention here Robert petoskey
destitutes you cranky repubblica ludovic
1920 1939